some of the many who fled fighting
between an armed group called M23 and
the national Army in North kivu Province
nearly 1 million Congolese here have
been forced from their homes during the
last year
they're living rough in calms scattered
around the provincial capital Goma an
Envoy to Roman Catholic Pope Francis
visited the largest Camp preaching peace
and hope
in the name of the millions of forced
migrants and refugees that move in
various parts of the world we appeal to
the Goodwill of the people and
especially to those who have a position
of authority in the country and in the
international world to build peace
people hear fear for their lives
we're really scared because we are close
to the virunga park we know that the M23
are hiding there
we have heard that some rebels in Italy
Province have killed civilians in a camp
we don't feel protected
in the latest attack in eturi Province
Rebels from an alliance of Malaysia
called The Cooperative for the
development of Congo or kodeco are
reported to have banned a camp and
killed more than 50 people including
children
kodeco says it's protecting the landu
community from another ethnic group
called Hema as well as the Congolese
Army
the United Nations says 150 civilians
have been called in this region in the
last two weeks alone
the Eastern Dr Congo has seen Decades of
conflict with more than 120 armed groups
including M23 and kodeko fighting for
land and for control of vast natural
resources including Golds diamonds and
Cobalt mines
but people are caught in the crossfire
more than 6 million Congolese are
displaced their relatives killed homes
and properties destroyed and lives
disrupted with no apparent and insights
Catherine soy Al Jazeera